The Descendants franchise has slowly
been releasing trailers ever since the
Disney Channel confirmed that a three
coal was under way
we've gone from thinking that Hades is
the good guy to the bad guy overnight
but now we're not so sure he fits either
category the latest promos have revealed
some very puzzling facts about Hades
watch until the end to find out what
nobody realizes about the blue haired
guy or a dawn under attack my oh my that
sounds terrible
descendants fans have been buzzing with
excitement ever since they found out
that actor Cheyenne Jackson was joining
the production Cheyenne is set to play
the god of the underworld still many of
us have no idea what to expect from him
at first many of us thought that Hades
was mouths father we also believed that
Hades was going to help mal and the
other BK's beat their newest threat in
the mystery trailer we clearly see Hades
helping the people of auradon after a
mysterious sleep spell puts the kingdom
into a deep slumber it's here that we
see Hades standing over Audrey's bed
while waving his magical Ember around
many of us also believed Hades to be
locked up on the Isle after all we did
see his large combat boots step out of a
Cell after Celia unlocked a cast-iron
door so while many of us initially
believed Hades to be a good guy the meat
Hades trailer believed us
to reconsider everything we thought we
knew on April 19th 2019 Disney
descendants released a short trailer
called is it Hades it's here that we
start to realize that Hades might not be
the nice guy he's pretending to be oddly
enough it's here that we also realize
that piston Bell decided long ago
stop those who didn't fit the auradon
rules we find out that hades knows how
to play some killer electric guitar but
we're not surprised after all he's had
20 long years to pick up the skill you
can tell that Hades is furious and
somewhat suffering from cabin fever by
the way he plays his instrument we see a
flashback of Hades trying to escape
through the barrier
Hades puts his head through the barrier
and yells and we have to say we kind of
feel for him
Hades holds out his Ember and start
draining power from mal in her dragon
form however he soon gets knocked back
onto the Isle Hades is clearly furious
and tired of being imprisoned at the end
of the trailer
Hades turns around and says ah you
shouldn't have come here but who is he
talking to is he referring to wind mal
in the vks returned to the aisle in
descendants 3 this promo left us with
lots of questions but luckily a second
trailer was soon released or a dawn
under attack my oh my that sounds
terrible on April 27th 2019 Disney
descendants released a full-length
trailer called meet Hades Hades narrates
the entire trailer which allows us to
see things from his perspective he
basically confirms that he's the one
behind the sleep spell by saying a very
sarcastic remark my heart goes out to
them
it's hard to imagine who would possibly
want to harm them
Hades also throw shade on King beasts
and Queen Belle saying that they
imprisoned everyone and anyone who
didn't fit into their Arden mold
spending 20 years on the Isle of the
Lost did something to Hades mind who was
once the reasonable god of the
underworld is now a sight to be feared
we know from the old Disney movie
Hercules that Hades is one of the most
easygoing villains sure he's done some
evil things but he's a god and he's got
a job to do Hades has plenty of motives
to justify his actions let's take a look
at what his motivations are first of all
Hades is a God who was imprisoned out of
the blue for no reason in particular
what's even more frustrating is that
King beasts and Queen Belle began acting
like they were gods themselves they
thought themselves worthy enough to
choose the fate of thousands of people
if the rulers of auradon weren't sure
about you they'd ship you off to the
isle to make matters worse the Isle is
super crowded and magic lists if that
wasn't bad enough innocent children were
imprisoned on the Isle where they are
born and raised under the premise that
freedom is a fantasy and hope a thing of
the past in this trailer we hear Hades
say that he never wanted to take over
our Don before but now that he's been
stripped of his God title and locked up
for decades on end he wants nothing more
than to repay the favor
looks like Hades has more than enough
motive to go around so what is the blue
haired God planning to do if escaping
from the Isle of the Lost was easy or
even doable villains would be pouring
out of the barrier in great numbers
unfortunately it's just not that easy in
the meet Hades trailer Hades reveals
that he's been watching over our Don for
quite some time now waiting for the
perfect opportunity to strike whether or
not Hades is mouths real father as a
mystery but either way Hades could
definitely work this angle to free
himself and his people mouths got a lot
of enemies who are willing to work
against her so Hades has a lot of
options dr. Vasily
Celia Audrey and uma definitely play a
role in Hades master plan it's very
possible that Audrey is in on the sleep
spell putting part of our Adonis sleep
and stealing Maleficent scepter would
make Hades the only person alive strong
enough to say
Vaudrey and her parents would do
anything for her even if that means
freeing Hades from the Isle of the lost
although it's been confirmed that Hades
is up to no good we have to ask
ourselves a one simple question
is Hades really a bad guy Hades has a
bad reputation but he's got a good side
to him sure he rebelled against the zeus
and tried to kill his nephew Hercules
but hey he was tired of living in Zeus a
shadow and after all
Zeus wasn't exactly the nicest guy even
though he's painted in a godly life
Hades is one of the only villains who
always keeps his word which is pretty
honorable Hades has spent so much time
on the Isle that he's beginning to
wonder who the real villains are he's
tired of being surrounded by ugliness
and poverty and he doubts whether or not
anyone on the Isle is truly a villain so
in the end his master plan has been
built to benefit his people is that
really such a terrible thing
depending on which side you're on Hades
is either the bad guy or the Saviour
either way he's definitely got a good
side to him so what do you guys think is
Hades as evil as we're led to believe or
is he just fighting for freedom and hope
like the good guys have done so many
times before let us know what your
thoughts are in the comment section
below and that's a wrap give this video
a big thumbs up if you're excited to
watch descendants three for more videos
like this one be sure to subscribe to
the things thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]